oh 100 i've got to say it it's got to be
mal
you know their relationship is lovely
and they really they they're just
they're equals they look out for each
other is he gone
he's gone i just want to let you guys
know that you all absolutely
crushed it as your characters i read the
books in preparation for this series
and it was just such a delight to watch
all your characters come to life and
jesse i don't want to put you on the
spot here
but from jessie's perspective who do you
think that alina fits best with
so no pressure oh 100 i've got to say it
it's got to be mal you know their
relationship is lovely and
they really they're just they're equals
they look out for each other
has he gone
you know kerrigan the darkling you know
very much appeals to one side of alina
you know there's
the part of her that wants to be
powerful and you know can steal their
connection and stuff i think
in terms of you know i'm all about get
someone who treats you right and mel
treats selena
so well and he really really really
loves her and
i just want what's best for my girl and
that happens to be right now that
happens to be mel
i'm 100 female as well incidentally
i eventually was team mel too but i will
say i was i was shipping alina in the
dark lane in book one i got to be honest
i get it why not you know young girl
she's exploring different avenues
why not take a walk on the wild side oh
i like that
how are you doing here i'll make it in
the books we do get this first person
perspective through alina's eyes
as a result we don't know that mal has
loved her since childhood as well
we don't get to see that archie what did
that mean for you in the series
to see that we get to see mal's side of
things and did that change the way that
you approach
him approaching this relationship yeah i
mean i was really excited that we were
going to get to see
each character's kind of point point of
view when i was reading the first book
and i'm reading it knowing i'm gonna
play now i'm like okay what's going on
what's going on how's he feeling what's
he doing at this point you know so then
reading the
actual scripts uh i'm like oh wow yeah
this
is good and people are gonna connect
with this and hopefully feel what he's
going through and go on this journey
with him and
uh empathize with him and you know
hopefully it gives the audience the
chance to understand the character a bit
better
we can let this one go sounds like a
trap anyway a trap would sound easy
this is something else ready the way you
embodied kaz was just so
spot on i'm very curious to know when
hugh lowry starred on house and he had
to walk with a cane and pretend to have
a limp
he actually sustained like real life
injuries from having to pretend that he
was
injured did you have any physical
discomfort having to portray that with
kaz
i had actually read about that and two
people i was telling them about the
project sent me an article about hugh
laurie and he huge so hugh is sort of
you know the warning sign to us all i
just made sure that i
stretched a lot afterwards and kind of
looked after myself um so
touchwood no nothing unto what happened
good
we want you to play kaz but we want you
to be safe kit
jasper was so much more fun on screen
that i could have ever imagined and i
loved him in the books
his shooting skills were so impressive
talk to me about
the practice and and what you had to go
through in order to portray that on
screen
thank you i'm glad that it worked i
wasn't a natural with it
it definitely took a lot of practice and
uh i was originally given
a couple of prop pairs on day one after
we all arrived in budapest and i tried
to spin it dropped it
smashed and they all told me it was the
only pair they had but then they gave me
they gave me another pen i just went
home and was continually practicing
trying to get them to go forwards and
backwards and then eventually over time
they just became like an extension of my
arms and i was constantly just using
them left right and center
i carry them with me everywhere i've
still got them
here's what i don't get we're gonna be
here all night
rude amita you absolutely crushed it
as an edge your knife skills to that
amazing aerial silk stunt to just
sneaking around
the entire show what was the most
challenging new skill that you learned
and then the most exciting skill oh
first of all thank you for such kind
words
when i was cast as inej and i find out
what she is capable of i hadn't really
ever been to the gym before i have had
terrible fitness
and no flexibility nothing at all and i
said to myself i wouldn't do her justice
if i didn't put in the training
even though you know we have a son
doubles and and my god we had an
incredible stunt team so i did do a lot
of training i went to the gym
i worked on my fitness i started
building my gardens up here
um and in terms of the aerial silky i've
again i had no
prior experience in the first session
i can barely hold myself up i couldn't
do anything
but luckily by the time we came to
filming that scene
and the training that i had put in i
could hold down a basic routine but all
the cool stuff that you see
that was my incredible stunt double
another challenging thing was
was that you know everything in six of
crows is a prequel to
what you see in in shadow and bone so
this is all new stuff
and for me it was really important to
find the beginning of inej
of who she is and who she is gonna
become
and i want to define that character
journey
and the choices that she makes and the
relationship
she creates with kaz and jasper it was
such a brilliant bloody experience i
will never forget it
and i know others like us and there
never will be
[Music]
you